hey leute und willkommen zu einem
vorschau bzw preview video zu der
minecraft 1.3 version die laut mourant &
play messe und gamestar und allen
möglichen
netzwerken bald schon rauskommen soll
ich wollte euch einfach mal kurz
aufzählen welche ganzen neuerungen es
geben wird ich habe das bisher erst
einmal gemacht was ich euch quasi vorher
die neuerungen erzählt habe und deswegen
würde ich von euch einfach mal wünschen
dass er diesem video entweder einen
daumenbruch gibt oder einen daumen
runter gibt und auch in die kommentare
schreibt ob ich mehr solche vorschau
video macht forscher videos machen soll
wo ich quasi schon vor allem update sage
was so vielleicht drin vorkommen wir
sind da noch mal beim update jetzt
draußen ist nochmal vorstelle was er
tatsächlich auch was also schreibt man
einfach in die kommentare ob ich mehr
von so was machen soll also die erste
große änderung des updates wird eine
modern bzw ich weiß nicht wie genommen
das aussprechen soll mit dieser mottaki
wird es möglich sein modifikation also
mods und andere plugins einfacher zu
installieren bisher war das eher der
fall das man immer in verschiedene
ordner und dateien durchblättern müsste
in einem in dem computer bis man dann
quasi diese minecraft jahr gefunden hat
wo man dann eben die mod dateien rhein
ziehen soll aber das soll halt einfach
komplett anders ablaufen dass man quasi
sein eigenes programm dafür hat aber
mojang sagte halt auch noch nicht wie
das aussehen wird angeblich ist doch die
entwicklungen dieser mottaki so schwer
dass die fans bisher schon so lange
darauf warten mussten weil es einfach so
lange gedauert hat das alles zum
programmieren und wahrscheinlich sehr
umfangreich sein wird und ob die akp
zusammen mit dem update oder separat
erscheinen wird es ebenfalls noch nicht
bekannt wurde von der seite mojang
beziehungsweise job und den anderen
leuten da noch nicht bestätigt so das
zweite thema leider ich weiß nicht ob es
leider ist oder es gibt halt schied für
den singleplayer modus früher konnte man
ja nur im multiplayer die konsole
benutzen und auch dort auch sich mal
einfach so eine spitzhacke bieten wenn
man meine brauchte aber ab der 1.3 wird
das ganze auch im einzelspieler im
survival und auch im creative modus
möglich sein bisher habe ich euch da
schon die schnaps ist schnaps
snapshots sich 12 22h gezeigt aber das
wird viel viel umfangreicher und nicht
nur so ein chat sondern dann auch noch
andere möglichkeiten das inventar wurde
ja auch schon verbessert dann das dritte
thema es wird eine ganz eigene minecraft
literatur geben also wenn man dann ein
buch meine fehler und ein irgendwie im
crafting tablet zusammenwächst hat man
einen beschreibbaren buch darin kann man
eigene geschichten schreiben und ab der
1.3 kann man die auch in ein bücherregal
für geschriebene bücher stellen quasi
sein eigenes bücherregal wo man quasi
man sich so ein buch aufnehmen kann und
das crafting rezept davon wird auch noch
verändert also ihr habt ihr habt ihr
jetzt schon mitbekommen da sind fast nur
sachen dabei die auch schon in den
snapshots gezeigt wurden nur die mod ap
ihn kommt noch nicht gezeigt werden also
eigentlich alle sachen die ihr bisher in
diesen zwölf de 21 b 224 a 12 22h mit
diesen ganzen snapshots die werden alle
die 1.3 kommen und dann noch die mottaki
und halt die ganzen sachen aus dem
snapshots werden noch ein wenig
verfeinert individualisierten halt
umfangreicher dargestellt so dann hab
ich jetzt auch noch eine kommentar frage
an euch und zwar findet ihr das mojang
mit den tausenden neuen features in die
komplett falsche richtung geht und
minecraft er immer mehr vom sandbox
geben quasi in einer art rpg verwandelt
oder freut ihr euch auf die neue version
und sagt hey cool endlich neue sachen
kann ich wieder ein bisschen minecraft
zocken also quasi was für eure lieblings
minecraft version so nach dem motto und
ich würde mich wie immer über den daumen
hoch kopf freuen und schreibt mir in die
wie schon am anfang gesagt in die
kommentare ob ich mehr von solchen
preview beziehungsweise vorschau videos
machen soll und dann will ich einfach
sagen sehen wir uns morgen im nächsten
part von the jump